one of these days I will get this thing
straight
so help me all right here we go all
right hey everybody happy pride this is
this is my throne to get the one I
couldn't make up make up my mind on a
look thing oh this is this is what
happens when you're trying to represent
pride but also go for freaking come at
me bro
at the same time so prideful yet
somewhat confrontational all at once
that's what this is going for so let me
I'm gonna sorry I'm gonna just this a
little bit more I like that better dad
is better get more of the rainbow on the
top that way so I'm digging it uh you
look fantasy
I use that word a lot I get my kid pride
and wrath all in one yes I can cover at
least two deadly sins in one go could
probably get lust in there too you know
we'll see
glasses are an excellent a yet these
glasses they took a little while to grow
on me I am digging them at this point
though longtime listener first-time
caller welcome you look like a Time Lord
really this is your idea of a Time Lord
make it finally back in the states oh
it's not who I am
Oh welcome back to I I would say welcome
back to stasis States isn't always
welcoming these days but um I'm glad
you're back
um love the lip call yeah this is new
this is uh is a villain themed lip color
a friend of mine gave me this
Oh a week ago like my sense of time has
gone to absolute hell
everything is bleeding together lately I
would love to see a Time Lord appear in
that outfit in a sense Time Lords are
all gender fluid that I mean that's
debatable I've seen some people say that
I don't I mean I don't read it that way
because the just because of the house
sort of forced by circumstance the shift
is but I mean it's it's debatable they
certainly do can shift around so so
straight people prior to likes oh look
here's the thing
I'm annoyed that it's getting as much
press as it is because like it this kind
of crap gets proposed almost every year
I just feel like it's getting more news
Inc this year and I just wish it wasn't
that just annoys me honestly more than
the thing itself cuz there's always it's
always it's always guys I I don't want
this to come off like an anti mail thing
but why is it always guys pulling this
nonsense that's not to say that I've
never met a bigoted woman in my life but
I never who pulls that kind of stuff
that's what I haven't seen do you like
Randy rainbow that name rings a bell I
actually don't know for sure who that is
I was on the last episode of Good Omens
oh really what scene what were you where
were you I was going on were you demon
mm-hmm I don't think straight people
need Pride week or month just have pride
and or love for yourself every day I
mean look there isn't a straight Pride
Day for the same reason there isn't a a
white History Month or a national men's
Day because those people are on top
it's implied that they kind of have
control of what's going on the rest of
the time by default so it's one of those
things that I often say that like look
all things being equal yes you could
have straight pride the thing is all
things aren't equal and so the reason we
have pride is trying to bring the people
who are not on equal footing up to equal
footing if we ever get to the point
where where we genuinely are on an even
playing field sure fine have you
straight pride
I won't go but come fine but you know
what it's not there so yeah uh greetings
from Paraguay well hello to you as well
actually there is a men's Day uh yeah I
actually even as I said it I did wonder
straight pride is the kiyose summer
sales event uh Michael Sheen was seeing
a hit of fire in heaven oh I love to go
back and watch that now see if I can
spot you white History Month oof do we
really want to revisit all that fair
point like if you actually want to take
a close look at white history it's a lot
of stuff that honestly as a white person
I just as soon not have to deal with
that said I probably should hey you
should come to terms with your own
cultural baggage if he can not everybody
can for various reasons let's see how
many rainbows are want are on you right
now well it depends on whether you want
to count the earrings collectively as
one or one each so if we do want me to
the one two three four five
make a straight pride not as
counter-protest same time counter
protest I mean like that's that's the
other thing that too to put it in direct
opposition with pride makes your
intentions very very clear my only gay
clothing is the thirteenth Doctor shirt
I have that too yeah plus hair is six I
don't have a full rainbow in the hair
though I mean it's really it's really
only two colors so I I wouldn't count
that personally so question what do you
think about the overwhelming amount of
exclusionist I'm in the lgbtq+ community
I myself have been yelled at when I
cried with a gender-fluid flag yeah as
much as we you know we say lgbtq+ and
you know we certainly have shared
interests because all the letters in
that are facing discrimination on
similar basis we are not a well-knit
group and there is a lot of infighting
between you know various letters within
that little alphabet soup which is
really frustrating I mean like the whole
thing with Gareth Roberts kind of proves
like being being one of those letters
being gay lesbian bisexual transgender
whatever doesn't automatically mean
you're gonna be cool with all the other
people who are part of that theoretical
community which is frustrating because
you'd think there would be more empathy
if for no other reason than like I said
you're facing prejudice against you for
similar reasons from the same kind of
people it's I like some of it I get like
I don't like any of it and I don't
excuse any of it some of it I get like
years ago I get it less now since I'm
sort of shifted to
gender-fluid and identify more as trans
but and like I use trans because I've
transitioned out of mail systems I don't
mean trans like I'm trans she's a woman
no still gender fluid but when I was
identifying as a straight crossdresser I
used to get some serious grief from
trans women and as much as that wasn't
fun for me I did get why they didn't
want me around because I basically was
what people would accuse them of being
me I was a man in a dress and given that
trans women get if thrown into the face
that that's all they are as a denial of
their femininity I get why they didn't
want me around again their anger would
have been more properly directed at the
people equate them with me rather than
at me for just being there but you know
misdirected anger is it's not exactly a
new phenomenon considering that everyone
in the lgbtq+ has faced suffering in one
form or another we'd have some common
ground you'd think so but like so many
coalition's it's only one we're focused
on that common ground that we do okay
the the problem is when we're not
focused on that and then we start to
bite at each other and that's not always
that's like none of us can get along no
a lot of us can well like there's always
some elements that can lower some
elements that have no chill for lack of
a better way to put it I haven't come
out to anyone as non-binary in my life
at all I'm out as gay but somehow I feel
like coming out as non-binary will be
something no one would really support
even friends non-binary is is a tough
thing of it and and you know non-binary
gender queer a gender and I do think
gender fluid is in this mix a little bit
as well but the thing about those is
that transgender what most people you
know not the umbrella term but when most
people say it they mean either trans man
trans woman that dynamic while a lot of
people aren't okay with it they can wrap
their heads around it cuz it still fits
the gender binary that there are only
two options man woman trans trans man
goes from this to this trans woman goes
from this to this still only two options
non-binary gender queer a gender by
gender gender fluid disregards the
binary it rejects the binary and that is
actually more foundationally disruptive
than transgender is and that's not me
like downplaying the bigotry against
trans man or trans women
cuz it's there's a lot of it but like I
said that they they're that is there is
not as much of a misunderstanding of
just what they are with trans men of
trans women as you get with the various
versions of non-binary so it can be
tough it can be really tough trying to
know who you can be safe to come out
with okay this was this comment was
blocked but I'm gonna address it anyway
you aren't special all of you're so
obsessed with sex it's idiotic okay
here's the thing
this is not about sex I don't get off on
this I don't do this for sexual thrills
I don't get aroused doing this I do this
because it taps into an element of
myself that otherwise I don't get to
fulfill in a day to day life so if you
want to say I'm obsessed with sex I'm
immediately gonna go you brought that
out not me who's the obsessed one here
so there we go I can address this stuff
calmly sometimes
ah see
sips water hahaha yes
[Music]
what nameless were what name would you
like us to use we're dressing this
fabulous way still don't care you want
to call me this Daniel you can call me
anything you want call me your you can
call me Vera either one works I even
done up like this I don't care unless I
detect that someone is like math is
using male pronouns to be a dick and
I've gotten pretty good at picking up
the vibe unless you're doing that I
don't care it's it's actually very
freeing to not care about your pronouns
anymore let's just say I never have a
preference but it's pretty rare that I
actually have a strong preference one
way or the other anymore
it doesn't happen very often how about a
fabulous ah car looking like a boss
[ __ ] mm gatekeeping in the community is
definitely my least favorite thing about
it though people can go hard on others
for their own identities which is
frustrating yeah I mean well the
gatekeeping is is almost kind of a whole
other thing because and it's one of the
reasons that I've always been very
cautious of labels in general because
the minute you have a label and like why
found gender-fluid it took me a while to
find it I'd actually gone for a few
years basically saying I don't know what
the heck I am you figure out what to
call it what if I wonder fluid part of
what I like it is because the word fluid
is in it it already denotes that like
this is a shifting thing I'm like that
covers things pretty well but the thing
with labels is people whether they are
the people applying the label to
themselves or others who also use that
label there is a sense of oh if there's
a proper name then there's a proper way
to do
which means there's a way to do it wrong
which means that either
some people might accuse you of doing it
wrong or I've seen people like this one
of the III pop in every now and then to
the gender-fluid subreddit and one of
the most common threads I see in there
is someone going am I allowed to call
myself gender-fluid or am i gender-fluid
enough like I remember there was someone
who said you know 95 percent of the time
I feel this way and it's only like 5% of
the time that I feel different about my
gender and like jumping in and telling
them you're still gender fluid that
there isn't a quota you don't have a
minimum percentage to meet you it
doesn't have to be 50/50 you still have
as much tried to use that label as
anybody else that's how I feel there are
other people in the community who are
much more geeky be about I mean gender
fluid is usually pretty laid-back at
least in my experience but certainly in
many elements of the lgbtq+ community
whatever your specific label is there
will be somebody who will tell you
you're doing it wrong
which frustrates the heck out of me to
see love I'd love to see in full bloom
side of you oh that's a fun way to put
it the new doctor has another season or
at least or is it the CI a-- assuming
that's something I missed question the
black mirror episode do you think it's
unrealistic that game disk cartridges
would still exist in the VR future no
because I mean technologically speaking
they're already outdated but some people
still like to have physical media so I
strongly suspect that that whole
striking Viper is the physical thing is
not just similar to buying a physical
copy of a game now when you can just
easily get a completely digital version
and download it onto the hard drive of
your computer or your ps4 or whatever
your your gaming platform is but some
people still like physical media and
especially you're gonna give it to
somebody as a gift it's nice to be able
to give them any physical thing so no I
totally buy that well thank you Connor
there's a movie from 1980 called
ordinary people this movie is special to
me because in many ways it changed my
outlook on life do give it a watch I
have seen tiny bits of that best oh
that's um Timothy Hutton is in that um
Robert Redford directed it didn't he if
it's if it's the one I'm thinking of
have you seen Poe's I have not
I've been subscribed to you for about
two years and although I'm like the most
Pinellas straight guy who doesn't really
get all of this I wanted to say whatever
makes you happy is great thank you and
that's that's the thing like I don't I
don't demand that people get me like if
you could just not harass me then we're
good my acceptance is an amazing thing I
don't have a base level expectation of
acceptance tolerance I do kind of have
an expectation for that or at least a
hope for it and I get a lot of it on
this channel even from people who put in
their comments hey look I don't get it
but okay and I'm so okay with that like
that cool cuz you know what this stuff I
don't get like about various people but
if I don't think they're hurting
anybody's like you okay that's it's
working for you I'm happy for you and I
I wish more people could could do that
thoughts on oh yeah okay so thoughts on
the good place ending with season four
um probably for the best because that
was always my paranoia with a good place
that it would just keep going in it
would lose steam because like every
season
been good like despite the fact that I
really was worried legitimately that it
was gonna write itself into a corner at
some point so if season four is gonna be
the last season and they know it they're
gonna close it out I'm like that's
probably the best thing I'm gonna miss
it so much but like that's probably for
the best
um do you watch channel Thomas Sanders
he is a marshmallow and very inclusive
of everyone I actually don't think I've
heard of him that would be a new one to
me did you see the article on Ruby Rose
addressing not being less be enough
because Rose identifies as gender-fluid
I didn't but I'm not surprised to hear
that um yeah
or or like the thing that you get a lot
have you watched tales of the city what
did you think I haven't seen that and no
I won't be reviewing that your noble
miniseries I don't have HBO anymore but
anyway what I was gonna say is what you
which will get a lot sometimes is
someone who is bisexual but will have a
long term relationship with you know
with one gender and then people will
start to claim Oh bisexuality was a
phase you're obviously yeah you're
obviously just straight or you're just
gay depending on what their current
long-term relationship is but like no
they're still bisexual they can be
attracted to both and they settle down
with one doesn't mean that that
attraction to the other is gone it's
it's it's almost like demanding that
bisexual people be polyamorous with a
member of each gender to avoid doing
that to avoid being boxed in like that
it's it's a lot of BS oh thank you
op op op op two let's get it in there
love people explaining asexual and
aromantic snow casually it's I mean it's
nice when things can get talked about in
simple terms are you aware of the
rationality rules trans sports
controversy I often wonder if people
outside of YouTube atheist scene care
about this kind of stuff
no I know and just from the sound of it
I kind of feel like I don't want to know
about it but no I I'm not familiar just
because a straight man is in a
monogamous relationship does not mean
he's not still attracted to other women
thank you James
exactly
it was door okay so this is ordinary
people it was directed by Robert Redford
stars Donald Sutherland Mary Tyler Moore
Timothy Hutton and Judd Hirsch won four
Academy Awards including Best Picture
I do like Donald Sutherland a lot I ask
what you think about more out of control
uh uh gender identities like where do
you draw the line I well I don't know
what you mean by that like I'm gonna
have to be more specific than that ik
cuz I'm not entirely sure where you're
going with that question 90% of my
relationships I've been with guys and
almost all my friends assume I'm gay
which I mean like and here's the thing
that's not necessarily an unfair
assumption for them to make well where I
get frustrated is when people say like
well no I'm bisexual and they go no
you're not you're gay you've been you've
I've only known you to be with with
people of your own gender so like that's
what really gets my hackles up is a is a
denial of what someone is if you just
don't know if you don't pick up on it
like that's fair enough but you know
well thank you Tracy Clough in
California no quest just want to say hi
and happy pride hmm pride for all will
you ever do more Buffy videos as much as
I love passion of the Nerds analytical
style I really love your rambling miss
they're both great in different ways
the only Buffy idea that I have that's
on the docket with no date planned so
don't ask me when I'll get to this is
Buffy is
the list of franchises to give the
sorting into Hogwarts houses treatment
to because like because I still want to
do more videos like that with with Liz
but it's it's hard for us to film
hopefully look a little more time this
summer to shoot some stuff like that cuz
I you know so far we've only done Marvel
phase one I want to do Marvel phase two
I want to do Buffy with her I'd like to
do Star Wars you know I've got a fair
number of franchises I'd really love to
get that tree meant to mostly with her
if I can Thank You Torsten much
appreciated I've seen that buy thing a
lot of YouTube where I follow on here
named Mike mgtv
has been very open about issues from
being by yeah yeah and it's it's funny
because you know like I said the the
gender fluid by gender gender queer
non-binary sort of thing that's I'm not
gonna say it's newer it's been around
forever but sort of like having words
that are in common parlance for these
things is is fairly recent um what I
mean by sexual you know LGBT was the
original lumping of letters and the B's
right in there and yet there's a lot of
bisexual denial it's it's really
frustrating you and winging media
inspire me to make youtube videos I
haven't started yet as I have anxiety
but I'm getting into it a few weeks or
months thanks for being you you're
important to me Thank You Jay and best
of luck I'm like the best thing that you
can do is just practice like just start
shooting stuff even if you decide oh
that's crap I can't use it just like get
get used to being in front of a camera
you know how humans and the culture can
transition I just by deciding to would
you become open to the idea or at least
temporary fully transitioning if it was
that easy if it was that easy and I
could ship back shore just out of morbid
curiosity and funnily enough I have
finished the book
I'm actually gonna be shooting the
review for that tomorrow that'll go up I
think next week so I you can assure your
parents okay the reviews gone up I've
read it so happy to be here with so many
of my tribe yeah it's great
any news on the by rep video I asked
because I'm by yes again the delay on
that is that the person who I want to
shoot it with it's a calm it is a
one-two combination of schedules
aligning and they really want to to prep
they they prepped more than I do so it's
a question of schedules aligning and
also them having done the research that
they want to do in order to have the
informed conversation it's going to
happen it's distinctly possible that a
non binary representation video will go
up first cuz I've actually already shot
that even though I wanted the bisexual
representation to happen first but we'll
see I just it's it's it's tough
scheduling is a [ __ ] like that's that's
reality I would love to do more
collaborations I've got I've got like a
I've got a list of like three people who
I who I like would you would like to
collaborate I'm like yes and like it
then it's just a matter of frigging
scheduling anything huh
like make up have a glass of Prosecco
you you - happy pride thanks for being
you
thank you Donna I hope the and then I
went back home and everything went back
to normal ending wasn't anti-climactic
the union was an anti climactic the
ending was interesting though like ah
you'll get the four of you you'll see my
thoughts someone else is probably asked
already but being fluid which pronouns
do you pronoun question everybody drink
um like I don't care like I the the the
complicated answer is that my pronouns
are situational my preference is shift
with my presentation the short version
is that I don't care because I don't
have an expectation for anyone to keep
up with my own personal feelings and
things shifting about in the past I have
said use lipstick as a marker if I'm
wearing the lipstick use female pronouns
um even though I'm not necessarily gonna
say I'm abandoning that like at this
point I just don't care like even with
the lipstick I don't really care it's
whatever
well thank you Gabe happy Pride Month a
famous playwright and actors said it
best love is love is love is love is
love it is about loving and respecting
all not about sex I love him respect oh
yes oh my god like it's it's so
frustrating that so many and again I'm
not all like oh not all straights as
people but that so many says people make
anything that isn't cisgender
heterosexual 'ti about sex even if it's
not about sex either exclusively
primarily or even at all in the case of
some of this stuff
and it's just it's I brought it up when
I talked about the whole thing of the
children thing because I think you know
people think we have to shield young
people from transgender gender fluidity
homosexuality and I think for them it's
a natural outcropping of the desire to
shield children from sex which how
healthy that is is another debate to be
had but it's a fairly instinctive
parental thing but like you're lumping
together people's identities that don't
necessarily have a lot to do with sex at
least not any more than being
heterosexual does but you insist that
it's all about sex and we're just over
here like I not so much really it's
people get weird hang-ups told my BFF
about you over vacation she's not a big
geek so much but she's a big supporter
of lgbtq+ well thank you for that it's
helpful when people recommend the
channel which has finally started
growing again subscriber count' wife I
finally I like have been hovering just
shy of 35,000 subscribers for like two
months and I finally crossed it actually
today so that was nice my family have
told me that you can't love someone
without having sex with them I'm asexual
and they tell me this every time the
subject comes up and it's just so
frustrating oh god really
that's their line like I I have many
people that I love and even have at some
point loved in a romantic fashion that
it does not have to involve sex I still
love my daughter's mother we're not
together in that way anymore
mr. lover I love Liz I
I have best friends who I will say that
I love them
yes it's it's a lot like the the
conflation of gender with physical sex
yup sex is in your sexual organs and
it's completely it's completing romance
with sexual intercourse and they're not
for many people they are tightly linked
and/or synonymous but they're not for
everybody and you don't get to say well
this is what it is for me so that's what
it has to be for you like no just no
have you ever thought of doing more
videos dressed like this like not only
in the lgbtq+ representation I don't see
more like this love of your style
um I mean a big part of it is like this
takes a while
there's a lot of work and this is a big
part of why I don't print like even when
I do the lgbtq+ stuff all I do is let
the hair down and like swap out the
glass and main put it like them bow in
or something I don't do full makeup
because this is the pain like I'm happy
with the results but like this it's
something I'd like some people genuinely
enjoy the makeup I enjoy the results I
don't enjoy the process particularly ah
sex is a DLC you don't have to get if
you don't want to sex is an optional
micro transaction that's what sex is
do you watch ASMR videos I actually
don't that's one of those things I'm
just like I don't get it like it it's
fine that's your thing cool I don't get
it whatever effect those things have on
some people it's it's it's lost on me
pain is beauty no pain is not beauty but
there is pain for Beauty pain for beauty
is high heels and false lashes and oh
you know what I'm gonna take this off
for a second so that I can actually show
off the lashes because you don't always
get the full effect when they're behind
the glasses there we go
WTF welcome to the channel Matthew I'm a
so does that make me free to play what
are you doing for pride this year for
Pride Month itself um not much because
I've mentioned this before Vermont pride
is in September
so there's like no events going on near
me one thing I don't get is when people
say being asexual is just a phase oh
yeah like it's um like this this came up
when I did the video with with Ming
Kobayashi
on on asexual representation there are
certain things that are just assumed it
is assumed that you will have those
attractions someday and much like it's
it's long been presumed that everybody
you know has a desire to have kids I
give if you don't have kids and you
haven't already had like I've had my
daughter
I've now also had a vasectomy so I'm not
gonna have anymore but the fact that I
have bred once people don't think too
much of it but if I got in the baths
ectomy without having had any kids
people would have been like whoa but
what what if you want kids I said I
don't and I won't and they're like but
but you will someday you will know and
that's how it is for some people it's
the same with with sex some people's
like no yes God so much stuff is a phase
if you're masculine being girly is a
phase if you're feminine being a tomboy
is a phase if you are bisexual that's a
phase a sexual it's a phase
oh so many freaking phases I'm not the
moon I mean this honestly when I say it
if I could meet any youtuber in person I
meet you oh my goodness thank you
everyone's performing their gender all
the time even since people are basically
just acting yes I mean gender
here's the here's here's the funny thing
people will sometimes say performative
gender as like and and that'll get
hurled at trans or you know non-binary
non-standard gender conforming people
like it proves that this is fake because
it's performative but gender is a
societal construct that does not mean
now here's the thing societal construct
is not the same thing as non-existent it
exists as created by the society that we
live in and gender is Vives nature
performative when I am masculine I am
performing masculinity when I'm feminine
performing femininity when I'm in the
middle I don't know what the hell I'm
doing but I'm biased nature it is
performative there is something that you
are doing most of us at least there's
something that we do to affirm our
identity the thing is since
statistically the best majority people
are cisgender we don't think very much
of a man affirming his masculinity in
some way or a woman affirming her
femininity in some way unless it is in a
manner that is so over-the-top it's like
whoa wait a minute you know like like
you know the the big the big dubrow
bodybuilding things like okay you're
overdoing how much of a guy you are or
yeah things like that unless it's a in
that level we don't think anything of it
because that's the expected normal like
everything is shaped by what is
quote-unquote normal but too many people
um default to the statistical minority
I'm sorry the statistical majority to
decide what is what is normal and that
anything that doesn't fall under you
know the the numerical majority is
there's something wrong with it
like it's not okay to be minority there
you go
hahaha JK Rowling hasn't told me my
sexuality yet well she will give it
enough time she'll get to you she she
gets all of us because let us not forget
that your sexuality is not something
that is determined by your biology or
your upbringing or anything else that is
something was stowed upon you by JK
Rowling over Twitter I don't really like
the feminine gender role but I like
wearing dresses and that's fine too like
and like that's that's another thing is
like for me putting on a dress serves a
function of connecting me to my
femininity but even if it doesn't serve
that function for you and you are male
identifying that's still fine to put on
a dress me drip dresses can be awesome
they're wonderful and freeing and flowy
and you twirl in them there are a hell
of a lot of fun not enough of them have
pockets but aside from that like dresses
are great and and there's no shame in
where you don't you can wear if you're a
guy you can wear a dress you don't have
to perform femininity along with that I
have really come to like your lgbtq+
videos thank you so much I enjoy doing
them quite a bit
Jake you were all except the bisexuality
is very important to my life but you
wasn't going to make it canon in my
memory yeah that sounds about right
aah would you adopt a youtuber from your
chat No cheeky
I love sundresses but suits are awesome
too I love like just personally like
taking a moment here
I love feminine present like
make up and you know not not not like a
drag king or fake facially like feminine
presenting in a suit or a tux oh like
something like some of the sexy speakers
and like there's pictures from the 20s
of like these Hollywood starlets in
tuxedos oh oh love it
I have always loved it what's the
opposite of a sexuality I think I might
be that I swear a far more testosterone
than the typical gal um yeah I did I I
would say it is possible to have an
overdeveloped sex drive that that's I
mean I'm not saying necessarily
medically I don't know that's a
condition but like that's something that
can happen one of the things I don't
like about the culture is the fact that
banks presumes the gender binary would
still exist in Utopia even if it if
going between them could be easy okay
see like I'm glad you acknowledged that
because that is something I'm going to
bring up when I do the review and again
like um you gotta wait for the review
for my full thoughts but it's one of
those things that I think is partly
chalked up to we're talking about the
the book player of games which I was
commissioned to review review will be
out next week I finished reading it um I
think the fact that it was written in
the 80s as part of that because there
are some elements that are in there that
at the time kind of would have gotten uh
oh that's novel just because they were
ideas that weren't being done a lot but
like things like the members of the
culture being able to shift their gender
very easily you know and almost had a
whim but it doesn't really do anything
with that and he didn't play out how
that would affect gender dynamics and I
again I talked that up to the idea was
kind of new I'm I'm not gonna say he was
the first one to come up with it um
because I don't know that but it he was
probably one
the earlier ones to put that prominently
in a book so you know he he wouldn't
have had the ground were laid by
somebody else where he would have
thought oh I should take that idea
further because he was just kind of
planting the seed a little bit
sex-addict not personally No
oh okay excuse me I got a ban somebody
and boom bye you should watch John wick
too if you want to see a woman in a suit
it's been a while since I've seen that I
haven't rewatched it what is the third
John wick coming out or it's out already
isn't it it came up that's that's
another movie that did not come out
where I am or has it not come out I
can't keep track and like my local
theater actually added on another screen
it's four screens now it's still not
getting some stuff anyone interested in
a utopian novel with a positive
portrayal of gender fluidity and
queerness should read woman on the edge
of time well I already like the title
just want to say I can't hide my Envy
pride well show your pride rusty what
and bless you and thank you stream is a
bit glitchy oh dear I hope so hope it's
not can any gender be a nymphomaniac
well yeah I mean again because sex drive
is not something that is synonymous to
any particular gender identity yeah
anybody can be a sex addict that's Blake
Lively in her suits and simple favor
mile I haven't seen that one
what do you think about RuPaul not
allowing trans women on her show I what
I'll say is that her decision to do that
is at least from my experience fairly
representative of much of the drag queen
community because the drag queen
community can be very gay TV i I
actually did a video talking about
whether or not drag is transphobic
on the wild channel um so that that's up
there if you want to check that out I
think it's actually the newest video
that's up there still I need to shoot
another video for that channel but um my
experience with with the drag queen
community is first of all incredibly
outdated I haven't done like a proper
drag show in like 12 years because I've
been doing burlesque but my experience
in the drag queen community RuPaul's
decision to exclude trans women is kind
of representative of what I've seen many
prominent drag figures feel that drag is
the domain of cisgender gay men and that
if you aren't all three of those things
are at the very least two of them then
you have no business doing drag you
really they really expect you to be all
three because I know I kind of got grief
because I didn't I didn't identify as a
gay man
like I did when I was doing drag I was
still like that playing as a cisgender
man my crossdress but I still thought of
myself as a cisgender but you know just
because I wasn't gay I got some pushback
on that uh let's say there was a potion
to change your sex within seconds
painlessly making it easy to transition
to either sex would you use one booty
yeah morbid curiosity if nothing else
you should do a special on the Timelord
houses speaking of Hogwarts I actually
don't know what ton about them
cuz that that's all like um expanded
universe kind of stuff which isn't
usually my bag not unless I do a story
like I do
I don't enjoy reading basically in an
encyclopedia entry thank you op op two
again some of the later books play with
the idea like in one a couple switch at
around the same time so they can have
babies at the same time kind of regret
not having a review that one I mean no
worries and like I said I wasn't
to slam the book on that basis so so
don't worry about it
not a regular thing but would you
consider streaming on the weekends
occasionally please
um no like it is the thing you need to
realize I landed on Tuesdays by default
um so uh my weekends are one of two
things either I have my daughter and
when I have her on Saturday nights we
have slumber party she actually sleeps
in my bed and plays her arms out and
digs her knee into the small of my back
so that's that's you know Saturday is
gone and forgive me for like not wanting
to necessarily blow Friday night on
these and the other thing is like the
other weekends are my weekends when I
don't have my kid which is usually what
I'm seeing Liz and I'm not physically in
the house so like I land it on Tuesday
because Tuesday was the only date that I
looked at myself and when I can reliably
do Tuesday every week yeah I'm not gonna
rule out ever doing a weekend livestream
but it's it's if I ever think I'll do
that I'll like I'll announce it in
advance and it will probably be like for
an occasion because like I'm already
doing a weekly pride all-around thank
you a lot of transgender youtubers being
honest about their life educational but
also some what's at it frequently is I'm
actually like incredibly lucky because
my own story is in no way involves me
being rejected by the people who
mattered most to me
I was never thrown out of a house I
never had someone say that you know they
they couldn't be my friend
anymore and that is a really common
thing in a lot of transgender stories
which is yeah it's sad Thank You Torsten
thank you very much but you know it's it
happens a lot but I've been super
fortunate like insanely so in terms of
just not having to deal with a lot of
crap um you know in my direct personal
life I deal with crap online but you
know don't we all
you already do a lot for us don't feel
like you have to give up more of your
own time
I just shift to my position at work so I
could spend more time with my family so
I get it yeah yeah I tried work-life
balance is it's it's not easy and it
doesn't it doesn't help like the the
office environment of the job that I'm
still at has shifted to them not really
caring about your work-life balance
anymore they care about your work work
do the work when we say you work and we
don't really care what happens at your
home so hmm fun stuff uh have you read
the book George I I haven't but I'm very
familiar with it because um so for
people who didn't know Liz is a school
librarian and she had a book challenge
like parents chap
she had George available for the
students and some parents of a student
challenged the books placement and tried
to get a banned from the library so she
had to go through this entire book
challenge process defending the book and
its placement there so while I have not
read George I'm very familiar with it I
just had an idea for a video you could
top ten sitcoms um like I know what ones
I like but the thing is there's a lot of
prominent sitcoms that I either haven't
seen or don't enjoy so and that's not to
say that like it would have to be a pun
but I like sitcoms
as a genre is something I usually don't
dip into I guess why does the same
reason that I probably wouldn't do like
a best sci-fi series on TV because like
there's so many that are good there that
aren't supposedly good that I haven't
seen um I'm trying to think in terms of
sitcoms that I like if I can come up
with a top 10 favorites um sending you
hugs from Michigan thank you
um so okay so sitcoms that I really like
the good place Brooklyn nine-nine geez
and now and now I'm drawing a blank
um I did like I'm breaking for Kimmy
Schmidt but I only did one season I
haven't gone back since then Cheers
okay Cheers of Beyond there definitely
that's the other I think I'd have a hard
time hitting ten to be completely honest
what is your favorite Broadway musical
it's probably it's next to normal
Liz is amazing I love her I love your
videos together as well thank you I love
having a wrong it's fantastic when we
can we can choose something together did
you hear the good places ending with
season four I guess I did
and honestly because I know it's at
least tied to my understanding it's the
call we made by Michael Shure who
creates the show I think it's probably
probably knows what he's doing
there's also character in one of the
books who deliberately becomes neutered
because she's a super ascetic huh
interesting
okay gotta go to bed workout tomorrow oh
geez hold on did I just lose everything
all right
it's back Frasier raised just okay
I like Cheers better uh have you sorted
Doctor Who characters and Hogwarts
houses no that's something to do list
that one I'll be doing by myself because
well I have got Liz onto Doctor Who it's
it's slow going because I want to watch
them with her so she's not just burning
through and also I'm I'm selecting a
viewing order for her and it's it's a
curated list of episodes I'm not there's
a lot we're skipping I love Doctor Who
but you know
liz is always awesome she's so nice very
smart and she's yeah yeah she is
what other British TV shows do you watch
other than the obvious not a lot
currently my mother actually just burned
through all 19 seasons of Midsomer
Murders that was her poison for a little
bit and that was after being on the
crown for a lot I think my brother
actually might be more up on British TV
than I am at the moment funnily enough
ever watch Barsky Gable I own the entire
set of Farscape all four seasons and
peacekeeper Wars
I like Farscape a lot second seasons the
best but I like that show a lot
Luther rocks I couldn't get into Luther
I wasn't I can't put my finger on what
it was about Luther that didn't click
for me but I couldn't get into it okay
don't know what's going on there Lucifer
being renewed brings me much joy though
the ending of the last season is decent
Lucifer I also couldn't get into gave
that episode 3 gave that show 3 episodes
and I don't know what it is something
about the actual guy who's playing
Lucifer he doesn't he annoyed me I don't
know I can't say why and like that's not
me saying that no one else should like
it a lot of people do awesome but like I
just yeah and he didn't do it for me
which shows you watching now current
stuff um well I mean I need to start
watching the latest season of legends of
tomorrow because I really like that one
I watched a good place which is now
ending um I mean I'll see West world
when it comes back I really don't know
where they're gonna go for the third
season I'm on that one doctor who
obviously like a lot of stuff that I
like is wrapping up or has wrapped up
we're getting one more seasons and
season of Jessica Jones crap that's
later this month is
that uh that's one more thing you gotta
find time for shear I really like Game
of Thrones ended Gotham ended man shout
out to vicious for those who haven't
seen it yet highly recommend the even
tweeners but if you're not from the UK
it may not be as good for you have you
watched a Barry it's really good I have
it like I dropped my HBO subscription
once once Game of Thrones and yes I am
that geek alright ladies got a bounce
it's 3 a.m. and I don't want to end up
talking like Austin Powers tomorrow
morning yeah baby yeah water yes water
when I was like 12 I read the only human
and loved it how do you deal with
finding out a book you love was written
by a not good person um I don't I don't
know because different people deal with
in different ways I don't think I've had
it happen with the book but there have
been movies that I love that are either
difficult for me to watch or that I
can't watch anymore or I haven't tried
to so some of my favorite movies like in
the past have included Braveheart Mel
Gibson the usual suspects double whammy
Brian singer and Kevin Spacey I adore
that movie I don't know what I'm ever
gonna have the stomach to watch it again
and mm-hmm I always thought that they it
still is one of the best regardless of
anything else but like one of the best
um stand-up specials ever made was Bill
Cosby himself and I that I died like
I've still got my copy of Braveheart and
the usual suspects cuz I'm hoping maybe
at some point I'll process enough where
I can try watching those again but I
flat out got rid of my copy of Bill
Cosby himself I didn't want it in the
house that's was how gross that made me
feel yes I am that geek great name for a
YouTube channel
[Laughter]
see
mm no actually as someone in the
comments just typing gay gay am I know I
mean probably not the way you're meaning
anyways I mean because I suppose that's
the other thing and I mentioned this
like in a Doctor Who video ages ago when
you have a fluid sense of gender like
what does gave you mean under those
circumstances I don't know that's that's
that's why I I don't use the term
generally to refer to myself and okay
you know what at this point it's
starting to eat up the check bear with
me for a second and bye-bye there we go
that was easy Kevin Smith yeah Kevin
Smith I haven't liked a Kevin Smith
movie in a while I would love to hang
out with him though I would love to just
just you know kick back and like with
friggin cheese fries and Irish coffee
and just just shoot the breeze with him
for like an hour
dogma I do like dog I think a last Smith
movie that I liked was probably Jay and
Silent Bob strike back which I also
haven't well no actually that's not true
I did like clerks to a lot more than I
thought I was going to so that's
probably the last one I haven't seen all
the movies he's made since then but I've
seen some of them you know it's it's a
it's a mixed bag
looking forward to your deadline review
later this month it's one of my all-time
favorite Big Finish styles
I actually just listened to that today
that's another video I've got a shoot
that was uh huh how was the thing I
really do like your lgbtq+ videos thank
you very much
clerks too was a pleasant surprise yeah
it really was I was I was really kind of
surprised how well that turned out I
went through the disconnect with a
favorite author that was ebooks actively
contradicted his professed ideology I
chose to believe the books and then I
dug deeper and figured out the reason I
mean that is that is something worth
pointing out is that it's not uncommon
for for there to be a disconnect between
someone's personal beliefs and what they
put down in a book not everyone uses
their creative works as an outlet or
venue to vent their political beliefs
and sometimes narratives that they write
will be devoid of that or will even be
in a direct contradiction because they
were writing what they felt was a good
story and if they weren't and if they
didn't have their political leanings in
mind the story might have gone in a
direction that actually contradicts what
they themselves believed that actually
doesn't can't happen not sure it happens
a ton but it can because Wow
everything is political in to some
degree because everything is created in
a world with context and the people who
created it have political beliefs
there's still not everyone is
deliberately inserting their politics
into things so how that factors into
your ability to continue to connect with
a piece of work created by someone whose
politics do you disagree with that may
be a factor that helps maybe it doesn't
again like I don't I don't
like to dictate how people should or
shouldn't deal with pieces of art by
people they don't like it's it's always
harder in the modern context when you're
talking about someone who's still alive
because if you purchase you know their
work you are financially contributing to
them when it's someone who is deceased
like Walt Disney HP Lovecraft I think
it's easier to to separate that in terms
of not feeling like you're supporting
their beliefs by liking their work
because they're dead you can't actually
financially support them anymore and
that's not me wishing death on a whole
bunch of creators I'm just saying that
it makes things simpler that's it
I want to eat my flan but I'm still too
full oh the struggle is real I just want
to eat everything I want to eat the
whole world Wow there are some
interesting things going on here
a woman can we expect the other black
mirror reviews um that the Monday so
smithereens will be when they coming and
then Rachel Jack and Ashley too will be
the Monday after that I've seen all
three I've actually shot the reviews for
all three but that's the pace they're
coming out
Oh somehow we've gotten onto Orson Scott
Card I was wondering I could I could see
like some of the things being tossed
back and forth I was like I wonder who
they're talking about Orson Scott Card
oh there we go
should have guessed and we are gonna
need to wrap it up the soonish um not
quite yet but soon
gotta run thanks for the stream thank
you for stopping in violet much
appreciated
I want to eat the entire planet made of
cookies cookies planet I have strange
tastes I mean I don't think cookies are
that strange of taste wanting a planet
of cookies that's a little unusual a
sauce fell down player of games with
bangs is very much put his politics and
his work did you get that banks was an
arcade and our kissed communists yeah a
little bit I picked up a little bit on
that is Doctor Who your favorite show
yes yes it is
ah I love Agatha Christie but boy wish
you problematic I mean like you're gonna
look at anything that old you are gonna
get that but yeah yeah if anybody needs
a primer on the ways in which Agatha
Christie was kind of problematic just
look up and then there were none
previous titles cuz it was published
under to progressively worse titles
prior to it currently being called and
then there were none
it's still it's still a great story and
I've seen it performed as a play and
it's amazing and I love it but who boy I
thank you for your lgbtq+ videos as a
query
I really appreciate them thank you I
appreciate that
I appreciate you folks because what it's
honestly even a year ago the idea of
even though I'd come out on this channel
by that point like the idea of sitting
here looking like this with my with my
hair down and makeup on talking live and
not being afraid that idea would have
blown my mind and yet here I am that's
funny
and sometimes amazing
hahaha I just looked up and then there
were non original title and yikes yeah I
did warn you oh thanks everybody
I do think I am gonna wrap it up I love
you as you are Viren Daniel thank you
almost God right of the Daleks ah
somebody had to get it in there goodness
sake we love you and your bravery Thank
You Carolyn
happened to me should I should I feel
just as offended to be pushed as you are
gay when you are not as is to be pushed
as you were straight when you are not um
I mean I'm not going to tell you how
much to be offended by what people do
but like I think you have just you have
an equal right to frustration certainly
if someone's going to insist that you
know if if you're bisexual or pansexual
or have any kind of mixed leanings and
somebody insists that you're gay you
have as much right to be frustrated with
that as someone who was insisting that
you're straight like the presumption is
that someone assisting your straight
would be worse but honestly either one
is denying who you are as a young trans
girl looking to change her hairstyle and
love yours may ask what the back of
yours looks like oh yeah actually that's
that's funny I okay so it's just so up
top is what's long and then all the way
around like it's it's it's outgrown a
little bit right now I need to I need to
get it trimmed but it's it's with a
number two Clippers for just the whole
way around that like the back like the
very back here is slightly shaped so
that it's not falling straight down
because when it gets too long like it it
just weighs straight down it doesn't so
this bag is slightly shaped to flow that
way where the rest of its going but the
reason the hair in general goes this way
that's just where my part naturally goes
so that was that was an easy call to
make
hang on got a band somebody here we go
and there we go that was another easy
call I don't enjoy banning people but
you know they come out of the woodwork
you deal with them when they show up
celebrate Alex must celebrate all right
the banhammer is a vital tool oh my god
yeah like that's my first recommendation
for anybody not even just lgbtq+ people
anybody starting a YouTube channel be
liberal with the block button seriously
if somebody's stirring up crap just get
rid of them you don't owe them a
platform so yeah I am I think going to
wrap it up you gay dude you lift bro ID
nine times out of ten when people ask me
that with what they mean the answer is
no I'm not because you're asking me if I
am attracted to men no my partner is a
woman she's been on the channel she's
awesome the wildling friend Jon Snow all
right all right all right yep I am gonna
wrap it up so I hope I hope everyone has
a good rest of Pride Month I hope that
people have good rest of the week these
[Music]
these live streams they honestly help a
lot sometimes because there's a lot of
crap that I'm dealing with that this
this honestly in a lot of ways 2019 has
not been great it's been kicking my ass
on a lot of levels but once a week I get
this little pick-me-up and it's nice so
next week it'll be seven o'clock
probably not gonna go through and not
gonna put all this on but it's amazing
to me that I could feel safe to do it
here with you so thank you for watching
thank you for supporting however you do
it like the donate the donations and the
super sad like it's amazing the page
runs amazing but just being here just
watching just listening to my nonsense
thank you you're beautiful you are loved
you are the council of geeks happy pride